[Musique]
qui est cette fille excusez moi je suis
110 watts l'heure on peut aller discuter
autre part je suis imprésario
sandy n'était pas une grosse pointure
c'était une toute petite pointure mais
il restait gravé dans votre mémoire
c'est bon ça
[Musique]
cette idée cette espèce de rire forcé
est là c'était pareil pourquoi se forcer
à rire c'est eddy murphy
il est super drôle mais où il en trouver
vous l'auriez rencontré à une soirée
vous vous auriez dit qui a bien pu la
vie t elle mon vieux bouche de la foire
langage des plateaux que j'appelle de
galles il a dû s'habiller comme un vieux
pépé ou hour à table il se comportait
comme un pignon la prochaine fois il
viendra avec son ketchup mais c'était un
grand après sarrio créé un véritable
artiste chez aux experts voilà c'est je
t'aime je t'aime comment tu peux te
préoccuper tout le monde sans jamais
dissocier toi même
c'est mon métier un agent c'est pour le
business mais un imprésario c'est la
famille je serai toujours tout pour
servir au mieux les intérêts de mes
jambes
s'il ya quelqu'un que j'aimerais être
c'est bien c'est pour ça que je suis là
on n'arrête pas une étoile filante les
scientifiques sont tout à fait formels
on doit se mettre au travail
pourquoi tous ses états ben parce qu
elle de coller un interrupteur
non pas du tout quoi
c'était pas moi c'était pas moi reports
depuis le début
au roi
[Musique]